[Applaudissements]
en régie à plus de jingle de camille
c'est fait mais s'en sort pas mal c'est
vrai bien mais coûte et à la productrice
qui me sort la vanne la plus ripoux de
l'islam j'ai craint déjà elle dit ses
sens sont comme d'aironi ordonné dans un
instant et s'afficheront pas de votre
écran il faut avoir du courage pour
appuyer sur le bouton de l'oreillette
pour dire ça mais surtout très en
confiance et tu aurais dû faire je la
fait son chemin et se reposera la faute
n'aurait pas dû en floride c'est comme
ma soeur
comme ça tout ce qui est à toi est à moi
fleury le salaire n'est que je ne suis
pas payée sur l'émission oui voilà comme
chaque soir petit échauffement quand
même qu'est pataca j'allais tout faire
c'est apporter les c'est ce qu'il
fallait pas quoi à la télé ce week-end
aux motos regardez c'est parti
[Musique]
jeannie moment dans les tribunes
notamment l'enfant teaser de mokhtari
antonio banderas
il est beau comme ces papas initiaux sur
les épaules dans le doubs je le connais
motus myriam tente d'expliquer un
phénomène assez simple mais elle a perdu
tout le monde ces deux degrés celsius à
degrés fahrenheit et ont multiplié
degrés celsius par 1,8 et ensuite on
ajoute 32 échappé belle en france ça
qu'on a à faire cette une conversation
entre un marin et une journaliste ont
sait pas de quoi il parle mais ça prête
à confusion forcé est ce que je croyais
avoir de trouver plaisir de mes yeux je
veux croire ce week-end théia baloche
qui a profité d'un petit séjour dans la
raison la ganache campagne de patoche
pour faire une virée à moto
[Musique]
et on a trouvé une trentaine qui ont eu
la peur de sa vie en testant pour la
première fois un casque de réalité
virtuelle blessés
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
pourquoi micro
comme ça rit et vaut tous les valises
monsieur castaldi là il a tous les
talents
non vous êtes redevenu bout non mais
c'est vrai si on lui dit moi je suis dit
les choses il a plein dimanche matin
jeudi était sur la pente besson roche
voilà maintenant tebani savez je lui ai
dit toi alors je vous ferai de mon mieux
j'ai eu exactement ce que je dis camille
je connais les attaques du week-end
c'est franc j'ai eu un dos week-end 8h40
un 8h40 la paix tu fais lire frérot j'ai
eu un flash
toi moi les gens s'en foutent si je suis
dégueulasse ou pas non mais c'est vrai
voilà que le chef non pas un mais je dis
castaldi normalement pour tout le monde
il est beau gosse podium il s'est marié
une quinzaine de fois ils payent plein
de provisions alimentaires ils appellent
ça des mof de télé voilà et je lui ai
dit là dessus sur la pente savonneuse
qu'il faut que tu redeviennent beau
gosse et qu'est ce qu'il a fait il ya sa
part fait comme toi
il s'est levé à 8h40 il était
dégueulasse et aujourd'hui c'est bien
ainsi les boues sinon vous écoutez
l'émission et voir mon ami je me demande
si vous l'avez coûterait pas mieux de
chez vous j'avais versé pour l'année
prochaine j'ai par signer encore c'est
signé auj
je suis ému c'est vrai bah c'est vrai
c'est une première heure signal wifi
première personne à signer là bas et pas
chez vous tout le monde est reconduite
je veux pas signer un truc avec moudre à
la faire dans les prochains jours je
vais pas promettre quelque chose et pas
pouvoir
et bah tu devrais c'est ce que je fais
toujours
gervais la finale de koh lanta l'inra et
comme chaque année c'est la fameuse
épreuve des poteaux les candidats il
passe des heures de bout en bout j'aurai
c'est l'épreuve culte à au bout d'un
moment tu oublié caméra parce qu'elle
nous a offert un moment très élégant
pour libérer sa gorge
[Musique]
pascal gillet a dors et déjà il a un
flair de ouf il sait exactement qui va
voter pour lui lors du vote final il
anticipe sur quoi voter je le vois voté
pour moi dit vrai moi je vois dit
l'album alors que les manches votre pour
se trouver des expressions hyper moderne
est acquise à qu'il pouvait leur je
cherchais de chiens périmètre des mad
men sait jamais tout peut arriver
le soleil brille même sur le cully mais
c'est aussi partiel ou qui a gagné
l'épreuve des poteaux lancé ce qu'a fait
tomber ses concurrents jérémy et
clemenceau
[Musique]
ali
l'artisanat s'est alors fait pour les
amateurs le nom du roi de mes chouchous
de cette saison c'est jérémy à il perd
fier d'arriver en finale grâce à
l'épreuve d'orientation
il était tellement heureux il a remercié
toute sa famille mais vraiment toute sa
famille la liste de didier deschamps et
les moellons dévoile ses remerciements
oh mon dieu mon dieu merci la famille
joseph joseph puisque tout ça c'est pour
ma grand mère ma mère mon père donc
maintenant que mes cousins et cousines
ma famille pas pu saler pour toi on va
sur les photos pour mieux capter à
minuit je suis là c'est là toi qui lis
poteau dit forcément plein interminables
sur les pieds des candidats qui galère
qui tremble orange comprend pourquoi ça
a duré moins longtemps cette analyse en
paille souliers agronomique la surface
de votre poteau va se réduire
[Musique]
allez c'est l'horreur et regardez notre
enquête sur la chute de clémence avance
on a découvert la vraie raison ça y est
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez nous puis quoi mais je vois des
gars comme chaque été celle où ce qui
connaît tous les pieds de l'équipe est
donc et chaque pied lui rappelle
quelqu'un les jeux c'est qui ça lui
rappelle toi allez je file du monde
arrive c'est tous les quatre ans comme
les mariages de benjamin castaldi avant
la coupe du monde et la ligue des
champions on a reçu quelques trucs au
regard dans le vague
janin supporters du real qui a tenté
d'entrer sur le terrain mais c'est la
crue sts de terreur la plus courte au
monde on lui souhaite un bon
rétablissement
les joueurs du real ont communié tous
ensemble ça peut avec un thé au
hernandez
il semble être le maxsym déni de la
bande tout le monde le bizuth s'il se
fait aussi une première fois et idriz
mois une petite claque dans la gueule
ce serait repoussé de six tonnes et
finit par carrément se casser la gueule
du truc
didier deschamps quant à lui prépare la
coupe du monde
on le sait son pire ennemi c'est pas
l'allemagne c'est les conflits plus le
presse notamment pour prononcer le
organismes et d'erding son début morgane
chaîne des relais mais on a trouvé pire
pour didier deschamps le mot
caractéristiques bien évidemment même
manière avec les mêmes car et c'est ici
que j'ai enfin je suis désolé mais rien
ne fait plus rire au monde on s'amuse à
placer la liste de didier deschamps dans
de nouvelles chansons c'est pas bien
mais comment tu parle à ma soeur
ngolo
[Musique]
aux sources et bourgeois alphonse elle
fonce les pêches toi
nabil des fois je vais faire demain
aujourd'hui moi j'adorais cette chanson
c'est le clip qui passait pas aller
ainsi avec lui je me titre j'adore mais
il a surtout annoncé maître gims elle
c'est vrai j'ai adoré la chanson et
l'auriculaire problème chez normal ou
normal
salut luis clim auto on attend ça c'est
ya quatre ans ah oui effectivement c'est
pas vrai fossé n'est encore venu encore
plus belle en vrai ouais bon d'accord en
fait vous vous de 707 l'intello de la
bande c'est pour dire des trucs comme ça
voilà comment mythiquement c'est
important de dire à une femme pour la
trouve belle très belle kelly voit la
mer c'est sympa merci arrêtez vous avez
la sphère padres que c'est gentil de
mettre une photo qu'il est bête ceci est
une parodie
j'ai regardé le reportage sur tf1 avait
des vendeurs forcé sa métier passe un
fort et et les clients tout ça et y en a
un qui a une technique pour essayer de
se faire de l'argent plus possible le
plus protégé par an sur les banques
c'est vraiment long quand même s'il est
écrit par jean michel mart stores de
marie hakima il y en a qui s'est
surestimé physiquement je pense il
retentera page et elle a une fille ou
sept mariages complet avec une tourelle
je rend la monnaie que je vous fasse des
petits groupes une version d' enquête
d'action gallant a trouvé le secouriste
qui a une voix très particulière si on
ferme les yeux peut nous rappeler
quelqu'un surtout vicié
les nuitées cri comme joey starr peut
pas partir dans le passing dernière fois
quand même alors encore en quête
d'action qui nous permet d'en savoir
plus sur les urgentistes mais également
sur les animaux je n'étais pas prêt à
voir ça le propriétaire est très inquiet
d'autant que les chevaux comme les
vaches ont une spécificité méconnus ils
peuvent se noyer par l'anus non
je fais pas très bas par la ja jean
bernard montiel genre spécialiste de
l'anus de 48 à nos jours où je disais ça
l'intéressé ça c'est hyper choqué et
apparemment les poules aux siens
les poules aussi pas et se noie par le
trou de balle vous vous êtes noyer votre
savez vous comment se calmer oui oui je
vous le dis
[Applaudissements]
bondé d'ailleurs petites choses avant de
partir si laconique vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à laisser cinq étoiles sur l'api
l'émission id voyance sur idf1 ariana
quand ils ont fait appel et de nouvelles
voyante elle s'appelle anne lise et elle
en plus d'être voyante ses confrères ah
ouais et douch plus debout ce matin
concerné j'ai l'impression qu'il me suis
le gars je vais te défoncer segpa et que
les moustiques
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une voyante mais en plus d'être voyante
je pense qu elle veut absolument que
tous les gens déménagent à mon avis son
mari une boîte de transport elle a chuté
de 10 à tout moment alors caroline autre
chose vous avez l'intention de déménager
non moi je pense qu'un déménagement
effectivement d'ici 3 4 ans quand même
qu un ronin un nom me donne un
déménagement pour moi sur les 1 an et
demi environ
non j'avais commencé à envisager un
déménagement devrait y avoir pour vous
un déménagement première chose
effectivement un déménagement de ça
c'est la première chose qu'un
déménagement c'est aussi le retour de
moundir et ces aventuriers ou alors ce
qu'ils nous donnent leur version de
l'expression mettre de l'eau dans son
vin on comprend mieux pourquoi fait pas
bondir et les universités j'ai pas
d'autre choix que de
entendre amical donc du coup ben voilà
on va peut nous dans l'yonne signale qu
on a enfin la vraie responsable de la
chute de clémence dans koh lanta ça y
est
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les parents
averti
[Applaudissements]